you have to have a plan in your life  for what's going to happen to you when  you hit your 60s and 70s and 80s and  maybe by then your 90s because people  are living longer all the time  how do you get a nest egg together well  the average salary in america is around  58 000  and so i'm going to give it to you in a  nutshell  you have to start saving in your early  years in your 20s 100 bucks a week  minimum minimum  but it's not just the saving aspect  you've got to invest that money so you  have to take that hundred dollars out of  whatever your activity is or you're  gonna start a side hustle maybe you're  gonna be a photographer maybe you're  gonna be a writer maybe you're gonna do  something else a separate job where you  can make at least you know 100 bucks a  week after tax and you're going to  invest it you're not going to save it  you're going to invest it  saving is what you have in cash  investing is what you put into the  market